Je veux te voir envoyer la raison des relations publiques
Pour moi, ce n'est pas n'importe quelle nouvelle que je
coeur, je veux te voir régner
raison pour laquelle PR me n'est pas une nouvelle
Je parle tout le temps avec mon cœur, il est temps
prends une décision, je parle maintenant au fond de moi
Je suis arrivé au monde et je pars
Je ne veux pas de plus en plus de moi
pour approfondir cette histoire, j'ai apporté mon
anzei j'espère et vis dans la mémoire je veux
et vie
s'il te plaît, embrasse-moi la bouche, je suis fou
quoi
fou, je veux vivre et me plaire
Beja bouche comme c'est fou
fou, je veux te voir faire la loi
PR moi, ce n'est pas parce que je n'ai pas dit quel cœur j'avais
Je veux te voir m'envoyer cette raison de relations publiques
Je n'ai pas déjà dit que je parle avec mon cœur
Il est temps de prendre une décision, dis-je
maintenant j'ai le monde prêt à consommer l'Homme et
Je pars, je veux tellement plus
J'approfondis cette histoire
Je perds mes désirs et je vis
la mémoire que je veux est
live P s'il te plaît, embrasse-moi si bien
c'est fou ça
fou je veux
vis, s'il te plaît, embrasse-moi
bouche qui
fou, je veux vivre et p comos et Beja
bouche folle
fou je veux
vis là-bas, s'il te plaît, embrasse-moi à grande bouche
fou c'est fou c'est fou c'est fou ça
fou je le veux
en direct
Oh